here's what you say when lizzo says
you're fat you go like this
you're fat
how about they got lizzo dude the lizzo
[__] is
unbelievable oh dude lizzo called you
fat uh yeah that
shouldn't bother you
just point your eyes in the direction
where the words coming from
you'll feel fine about it
I mean for [__] sake that's like
calling Steve Buscemi ugly hey just
point your eyes in the direction that
the words are coming from you'll be all
right
who said that oh you you think I'm oh
I'm fine hey also
dude and you know did
dude
she pressured me into she precious she
that's the thing she pressured me into
touching a banana that's coming out of
another lady's vagina hey
say no
I'm I'm good now that you should I'm
good now but you should hey I'm out of
here
oh yeah well you're fat
oh you're gonna hear from my lawyers
dude here's what you say when lizzo says
you're fat you go like this
you're fat
also here's the thing they were in a
party environment and they put a banana
in the ladies vagina or whatever which I
don't condone no fruit goes anywhere
except in the mouth I feel like right
unless honestly if you think you can get
a watermelon up your anus then okay
straight up I want to see it
I want to see it go down
just put it in your anus and burp up the
seeds they were having a party they
stuck some bananas up some Uchi Wally
and they say Hey you know touch a banana
hey hey you should do it no okay oh hey
hey oh oh I touch the banana oh God damn
it ah and then you know it turned into
what's up we're all fat [__] you fat
huh [__] and she's like yeah okay you
know it's just like you made me touch
the banana and then you're talking about
my weight and you're you're not it's not
like you've seen a treadmill very you
know recently so it's like oh
and then some ambulance Chasers came
through and was like hold on they did
what and you worked for her so hold on
that's workplace harassment and it's
like dude come on we're all gonna be
dead in 20 years anyway there's aliens
think about how in 2000 if Congress was
like yo there's aliens we would have
stayed indoors for seven years and now
people are like uh hey there's aliens
and then someone else is like yeah but
lizzo called me fat
and and Jamie Foxx hates Jews
and you go
hmm good point
it is so crazy dude so guess what dude
namalizo fan
I [__] love lizzo dude don't know one
of her songs what's the one that goes
I'm that [__] I'm 100 that [__]
a stick of banana in your Uchi Wally
um so yeah dude it's like they're really
coming for the black people man now it's
like lizzo and Jamie Foxx but this is
the thing about the woke they just they
don't they don't give a they don't give
a this is why it doesn't pay to be woke
Liz always woke as [__] with all the
what's her thing called
big girls or whatever with no eye
big girls she has a show called big
girls
and people are like oh you know it's
great she's giving you know plus-sized
women which is like you know
I mean
chances of dancing or what I don't know
what they do they dance
it's just too it's all good
it's too much but it's all good but it's
too much but it's all good right but the
aliens are good we're gonna be dead 20
years is good you give us 20 years
I'm just like you give us 20 year I
don't think so